[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new michael keaton
batman video we have some more details
about what's going on with him during
the flash
flashpoint movie as well as the future
justice league dceu movies
it's also comic con week i'll be doing
videos for all the big trailers and the
things that they drop so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all those
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know which other
dc movies you want to see michael
keaton's batman show up in
i'll just number these as we go along to
stay organized starting with number five
so michael keaton's batman
is supposedly not going to be any kind
of substitute for the thomas wayne
batman of the original justice league
flashpoint story
but michael keaton himself is not
playing thomas wayne batman
just to be clear a lot of people saw
that he was an older batman he seems
like he's going to be super hardcore so
they just naturally assume because it's
a flashpoint story that thomas wayne
would figure in
but michael keaton is not playing thomas
wayne he's playing an older version of
his bruce wayne from the tim burton
movies
there's no version of thomas wayne
reportedly from flashpoint in the movie
at
all there was a little while where
jeffrey dean morgan seemed like he was
reportedly in talks
but my assumption is is that once they
knew that they could get michael keaton
to come back they swerved completely on
the thomas wayne character
in favor of older bruce wayne batman and
it's just going to be a completely
different version of the justice league
flashpoint story
when his batman shows up during the
movie we'll find out what he's been
doing
on his earth since the events of batman
returns the events of the joel
schumacher batman movies won't be
treated as canon in batman's history
like batman forever batman and robin
that'll just be treated like an
alternate universe there were some
moments during crisis on infinite earths
where they referenced his batman so you
have to take that as being another
alternate universe version of michael
keaton's batman
because it was so much justice league
crossover with ezra miller's flash in
crisis on infinite or sort of connecting
the dceu
to the arrowverse there might be some
small references to that during the
flash flashpoint movie but i'm not
expecting them to try and connect too
many things
i did a big video on some deleted scenes
with michael keaton's batman in crisis
on infinite earth so i'll link that
video at the end of this
there were a couple inconsistencies and
some continuity errors that i addressed
during the video but i kind of explained
what they were trying to do with michael
keaton's batman
during crisis on infinite earths next
big thing the movie will not include a
version of the atlantean amazonian war
from the original justice league
flashpoint i think we kind of expected
this but in that version of events in
the original story
aquaman's atlantis had sunk most of
europe the amazons had conquered pretty
much all the uk
and when the movie is starting to heat
up they're in the middle of a war with
each other the amazons versus the
atlanteans
after an attempted alliance because
wonder woman has killed
aquaman's mira like everybody remembers
that comic book moment where wonder
woman wound up killing maxwell lord like
oh wow this is hardcore wonder woman
they kind of did a version of that
during flashpoint darkest timeline
wonder woman in darkest timeline aquaman
arthur and mira had been married he'd
already been king of atlantis for a
while so she was his queen so naturally
the atlantean people were screaming for
blood
it gets super spicy this is like the
spiciest version of the justice league
darkest timeline that you've ever seen
the alliance fell apart when aquaman and
wonder woman had an affair
outside of aquaman's marriage mira found
out about it
it kind of sounds like days of our lives
with the justice league characters she
confronts
wonder woman about it and wonder woman
winds up killing her in combat
being a much stabbier version of the
character instead of the peacemaker she
is from the comics
the war winds up ending with a giant
nuclear level
atomic blast as they detonate captain
adam himself
like literally detonate his body causing
a mini supernova event that effectively
is going to wipe the earth clean of all
living creatures but that's basically
when the flash says okay thomas wayne i
will go back and change things again to
try and save
my earth so as the flash is running to
create another flashpoint event that
sort of wipes the timeline
simultaneously while the earth is being
wiped in this giant atomic blast
this way you start to see all these
impact frames and things just go
completely white
but it's for those reasons that this is
the darkest timeline of the justice
league just meant to
make the flash feel even worse about
trying to alter history to benefit
himself i want to save my mother because
i miss her so bad
but this is what winds up happening they
literally destroy the entire planet
the report that's talking about them not
doing the big war during the flashpoint
movie doesn't say anything about wonder
woman cameos or aquaman cameos i'm
assuming that if they appear
it'll be a very very minor appearance
but next big thing is the michael keaton
batman will be a batman from another
universe of the multiverse he won't be
part of the dceu continuity when he
shows up for the first time
ben affleck will still be considered the
batman of this main earth that ezra
miller's flash comes from
the new robert pattinson batman will be
from another
universe too but matt reeves isn't doing
any big multiverse stuff in his first
batman movie
so don't worry too much about what's
going on with that as it relates to
flashpoint in justice league
it's not meant to be a prequel to any of
the ben affleck batman movies including
justice league batman v
superman it's just being treated like
its own little bubble of continuity if
they decide to connect it with the
multiverse later then that would happen
with some other movie
a while ago though ezra miller did have
this big speech going on about how they
were going
full multiverse in the movie making it
sound like it would go beyond
just one alternate version of earth this
is him talking about that
fair warning he sounds like he's a
little bit high when he's talking about
it
we're talking about sparking a whole new
universe which is it's not just the dc
it's multiverse it's also it's the
speedster multiverse and even if they
don't have a post-credit scene like the
ending of crisis on infinite earths
where they show
many different alternate realities and
big scenes they might opt for just a
simpler shorter visualization like the
flash tv show did
back in season 2 when they did
multiverse for the first time
like we saw earth 90 barry allen also
played by john wesley's ship it took him
a couple years to actually do that barry
allen on screen in an episode but they
finally did pay it off
so number two in terms of other major
characters showing up my hope is
besides cyborg which they've confirmed
will show up during the movie
is they do a bigger cameo for john
wesley's ship as some alternate version
of the flash
either jay garrick or another barry
allen i'll be happy with anything just
put him in the movie somewhere in the
background
they're doing the justice society during
the black adam movie for the first time
in the dc eu and it's implied they might
do a version of jay garrick as part of
that team but they didn't see who he'd
be played by it'd be amazing if they
also do john wesley's ship as jay
garrick during that movie but i'm not
expecting
that much john wesley ship in the big dc
movies i'm also hoping for a possible
really small grant gustin cameo that
might be harder to pull off if they're
still filming the flash tv show when
they're also filming the flashpoint
movie because it's going to start early
next year
but just a short cameo scene to pay off
the justice league cameo scene with ezra
miller's flash during crisis on infinite
earths
just to be clear during that scene ezra
miller's flash is learning that he's
called the flash for the first time
because no one ever called him that in
any of the dc movies
that'll start with the flashpoint movie
he also says that victor was right
referencing a conversation that he
apparently had with cyborg
about the existence of the multiverse
during crisis they wiped every single
universe but they never really told us
which number
the justice league universe was they
never included it in that big post
credit scene so there's no number
designation given to it
so you can just theorycraft about which
number it is but number one
really big thing which other movies is
michael keaton going to appear in during
the future and what about live
action batman beyond so michael keaton
is reportedly signing on for multiple
new dc movies but some of those would
just be small cameos some of them would
be bigger appearances
the articles that talk about him coming
back talk about other big justice league
crossovers
the batgirl movie and earlier on kevin
smith's podcast he and his co-host mark
talked about michael keaton doing
a batgirl movie but warner brothers
doing it as batgirl beyond like
the old bruce wayne mentoring a younger
version of batgirl
but the way they talked about it made it
sound like they were gonna combine
two different movie concepts like do a
batgirl movie but also do it as a batman
beyond movie so a lot of people are like
wait a minute are they not gonna do
real batman beyond a little while ago
separately
the rap mentioned that a potential
batman beyond movie
would be its own thing and it would be
more comic book accurate
the bat girl movie would still be a
straight up batgirl story like you would
expect it to be
it's just that she might wind up being
from the same universe the same earth as
michael keaton's batman
then the potential batman beyond movie
would still be
terry mcginnis batman and michael
keaton's older batman teaming up
just like during the original tv show my
only assumption there is they would
probably wait till after matt reeves has
done a couple of his batman movies with
robert pattinson
because even though there's a lot of
different batman running around between
ben
affleck's justice league snyder cut
batman the newly returned michael keaton
batman
and then the new robber pattinson batman
is that they only want to have
one movie with batman in the title in
theaters at any one time
but let me know in the comments if
they're going to be multiple crossovers
with michael keaton's batman and other
justice league related movies
which other movies do you want him to
appear in outside of the flash
because it is comic con week right now
there will be some big trailers dropping
this week of course i'll do videos for
that
will you wait for everything click here
to learn about that michael keaton
batman deleted scenes from crisis on
infinite earths
and click here for my new justice league
snyder cut trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you